I got scammed did I tell you got scammed
no love it what happened
there's a guy no oh you told me this
story did I tell you a third time I did
I'd say it on the podcast yeah you did
really why did in Africa no six grand
yeah you haven't heard from since right
you don't know I can tear it from the
amazing scan part is that he's like yo
what's up buddy
I got your money soon I'm like no you
don't you lied to me the guy they call
me crying on the phone saying you needed
baby he's he's a baller Mercedes well
you know women obviously live in you
know living large all the time always
eating out like he's I know him for
years I like him oh I got a text I need
I need a grin brotherly love I'm [ __ ]
my my I'm dealing kratom what uh-huh my
venmo accounts been frozen I'm like what
I don't know what that means I hear I'll
give you a grand bro I should have asked
you I need another 14 I'm like what he
gonna keep it so crazy I don't know him
I'm like you're good for it you have
money I don't care I go if you need what
do you need I got what is this excuse
you think you mean I don't want to talk
about if you need it I'll give it to you
I'm sure you'll pay me back
of course you'll pay me back I see you
bro I gotta get another lost or should I
give him five grand
all together cuz he keeps asking but
it's like these he's coming back I'm
coming back I'll just give you cash plus
an extra GI gonna be extra jegos I'll
give you a cat can I give you cash I'm
sorry I have it in a pit stay at the
positive buck he's a gambler
oh the factional gambler so I'm like I
don't know what's going on but if you
really need money I don't know what this
is so weird but you're anyway I realize
he calls me crying he needs even more
money I go oh this is oh I'm not gonna
see my money no never
Oh cut to three weeks later still a man
I'm gonna get it back Mike till the job
so say he's got a dose I'm gonna go
ghost man you hustle them for first time
I've been I've been hustling I was like
that's someone you know that's you know
you know it's not hustle because you
know it's a right it's like such a weird
I was like she can be frank it's awkward
I go and I always said I wrote back I go
embarrassing dude
in Paris I know it's chump change what
do you wanna know man
I like around like it like that I got a
family a whole food yeah well not a big
deal it's not I just write them off
though huh what's he doing and kratom
but some people can do that they'll rip
you off like it's no big deal like
though it's nothing to them yeah and you
let yo pass yeah but there's a whole
thing around and they stay in touch with
you and they're like and you're like
what are you doing terrible you'd be
safe here's the thing with sex let's say
in you're in your prime and yeah you
know you had your prime right so let's
say oh and you let's say come on bro the
list No
so let's say in your no let's say you're
like in your 30s in your prime right
2020s right and you're just busting nuts
and you got a dime piece yeah and you
just got nothing to do all day but [ __ ]
yeah how many nuts can you get off let's
be realistic that much let's say five
and at the most
fives means Supachai most I would say
three three is prime or realistic for if
you're just sir hump a lot and that's
and you if you're in for doesn't last
that'll be a day that'll be an animal
don't say that [ __ ] yeah that would
be tough yeah why are you looking like
that to for even three days so most I've
ever done was five in a day not doubtful
I've done four G's yeah but but when you
bust that fourth ones like this yeah
dust you know I just just come rows like
your dick coughs no it's like it spits
goes your dick just goes it's barely
anything don't go oh don't do that
so my dick does coughs we F you're old
no it's as it goes your comes out like a
powdered milk uh-oh here comes nothing
yeah I mean sex is very temporary you
know it's like it is somebody said is a
woman that rich time our woman at Gold's
Gym these two in real professionals with
impossibly fake tits loved it and they
were hookers and one of them said well
when sex is good it's 5% of the
relationship when it's bad it's 90% of
the relation
in other words when it's really shitty
like you're like what am I doing here
and it's everybody think about when it's
really good it's awesome that's 5% think
about how much how much time during your
whole day with a relationship you
actually spent [ __ ] the weather when
the rest of times hanging out for
cooking talking having to deal with each
other you know what's that say average
time of sex seven minutes
I saw 19 I believe not average of five
to four minutes every time you have sex
yeah there you go
no nineteen that's not really that fun
I'd be a night teen about save me a
[ __ ] break
I don't do anything for 19 minutes in
that funny how people are like yeah to
be banged all night well well it didn't
bro and if you did she didn't enjoy
because that longed is not great yeah
food or sex cat food hands down yeah gin
food for sure no choice right now so
food it's good well it's very easy would
you rather be completely satiated
sexually or would you rather be hungry
all the time that's a no no I'm not
saying hi now but I'm just gonna pill
food is that dude I wish they had a pill
you just take me to have to eat I think
just gives you like all the right
nutrients some days for sure man some
days your life is driven by food why I
think there's a drink like that it's
called Soylent oh yeah I remember that
that can't be healthy
no yeah very sick they advertise it as a
health drink well that's like ensure
ensures what they give cancer patients
if you look at it say you buy it it's a
can that you buy in the supermarket and
people actually think it's good for them
it's skim milk with a bunch of your item
ins add to it sugar it's not giving you
and then you ain't great white sure yeah
we went to great white I didn't see that
I don't see the hell Brown and then also
you got a dicey situation velvet that is
what happened that guys just stand there
that wasn't me either
Oh either way you had fun though man
food was good yeah food was good this
guy's crazy what's this guy doing man
halt stop is the elephant whisperer is
he ever he's not my Alan mix myth Safari
I didn't do that either
so at the end of the day I got to pet a
cheetah and anybody who said that she
was drugged they're so stupid he was
definitely tired though
no that's what that she told her and
that she was hand reared but the cheetah
lives in the bush
the cheetah takes down we saw killed the
cheetah had killed that cheetah is as
wild as it gets
however it was hand reared and it's a
one-in-a-million cheetah it enjoys being
pet by everybody so it's it so what left
a wild cheetah it has a readout
transmitted hold'em um you go and find
it it has a rate of trails go find it
and then you can pet it it was fun raisi
so but but how did it know to sit there
and take pictures who told it what today
it sits there because it loves this one
guy the guide that's there that raised
it from it's been around it's in some
kind of its own its mother time I guess
it might have been printed on him long
story short it goes out it does its
hunting and everything else and you can
always find at certain places he's all
holders so sometimes they bring him a
cow leg he'll eat 20 25 pounds of meat
in a sitting
but that day they actually can be quite
affectionate to cool he just sat there
and I let me pet him like don't do that
[ __ ] was it he wasn't that big dog
there's 80 pounds and long
I wish it all ran it's bigger than you
think why they're not even run off kids
are around you you'd never let the kids
run around never because they're their
prey try yeah I wouldn't let my kid
around that [ __ ] well that that I was
a little bit you know concerned about
that yeah I'm not gonna let my kids know
I just don't trust an animal with that
[ __ ] thing you know every time when I
was next to it you could hear it like it
purrs all you can do at any time like
you know what I'm annoyed think well
when I watched it get up it got up
really quickly and then and it saw
something in a distance I was gonna hunt
and I was like this thing is a [ __ ]
machine and then it would just disappear
then we just run off from the bush and
then come back we saw two days in a row
and then it just disappeared we didn't
see it again but it's in that game
reserve which won't though yeah what do
you think it's in I think I'm heat on I
think it has hip issues mmm it's
bowlegged but they do fight you know
they do like certain people like this
guy it he would call it and it would
just show up out of the bush did you
hear about that uh that lady who was a
volunteer that's a lie who that's a lion
and they thought they locked up all the
lines along with
go double round here like things out did
if anybody says that this lion is safe
to pet why will never pet a lot
remembered any lion will you just put
yours just [ __ ] cheese didn't finish
she just don't attack people who says
that I know Tina God the guy said the
guy said that she died I never attack
balls-deep name's cheetah lions
different story
why you know he does a [ __ ] personal
they they would if they could they go
they don't do that they're not and
they're not as big they're an 80-pound
animal that can still [ __ ] you up but
still I am though a 500-pound lion 400
pound 300 pound female lion dude I'm not
fussing with any of them yeah Kanye West
crazy we have that in the herd events
you would be definitely its best suited
he's on Rogen's I agree they can talk
you wouldn't be joking around you guys
hey no we can get we can't talk about
health issues in fact your brain could
it's not really our thing especially for
an hour I don't think people with the
fans would key in I think they would
like it I think to get what recovery
answer dude there's no better platform
or what Rogen does even if it's only two
hours but where and that you know what
he does he's the guy for the five the
kids not this spot yeah that's not
that's not a couple you another like
sway interview if he was in here yeah
correct
he'd do another what he did an interview
with a radio host named sway where he
was basically yelling at him the entire
time really yeah why uh a lot of
different reasons yeah he's just a very
passionate he it's gonna be interesting
with jokes I see Joe very level-headed
but also doesn't take [ __ ] either self
kind a like start saying like Joe calm
Alan's questionable [ __ ] yeah it's gonna
be in Psych aunt wait yeah probably the
most downloaded show of all time Joe
will probably do a lot of listening you
know
well Kanye go for sure but if says crazy
[ __ ] Joe's not just gonna scare my half
state which is but and what else is
interesting is Kanye's do is link it
with Charlemagne but Charlemagne
recently started like not talking [ __ ]
was like dude I need to get back on his
meds he's talking some crazy I've seen
Charlemagne call Kanye I'm out like on
the show like when he had Kanye on he
was very direct about you know Sam I
decide to go you stick to music it's one
thing when you
start talking this way we kind of lose
our bearings with you you decided to go
different uh I really like that
Charlemagne guy he's really good yeah
did he start off as like kind of a troll
in the beginning he started off as a
radio host yeah a troll yeah yeah then
you saw me news on Wendy Williams for a
[ __ ] grip and then you know he's not
young he's like no he's 32 wonderful for
a hot set he's a smart dude I like him a
lot he talks a lot of [ __ ] yeah like
he's he's getting clubs where he dies
trying to jump him he just runs out like
oh there's a lot of [ __ ] yeah there was
that one dude who came up who is this
big producer Birdman you tell my
apartment yeah yeah I think you showed
me yeah I'd be scared shitless if those
people were like this yeah but he's just
like you you know his co-host DJ MV was
in New York and also was talking to Sean
on the show and he got held at gunpoint
that's what I can imagine these guys
about yeah they run with actual gangs
guys that you're talking [ __ ] on the
rappers some of the rappers run with
actual real goes when you see my back I
pull myself up like a champ like a chimp
30 times fast
while talking to you why wouldn't I give
that to you as it's a gift it's a gift
it's a gift